alright I'm bouncing I'll give you guys
10 seconds to take a screenshot to enter
the contest
[Music]
in the experiments in love the people of
Boston love them hate the Patriots
heading to to client meetings here in
Boston and then heading to the airport
Logan and on our way to Sweden for two
days with babban here which is exciting
a little takeaway something interesting
is emerged over the last couple days
three or four people have called me out
for public debates on subject matters
and I can't figure out what the debates
about other than they're trying to bait
me and goat me into giving them exposure
for whatever thing they're up to which I
will leave respect in that 3% gangster
kind of thing but the truth always wins
and like everything's on the record and
all of this stuff happens publicly and
your grandkids are gonna make fun of you
for not doing the right thing so I don't
get it like I understand if a Patriots
fan here in Boston wanted to debate me
about football but people are trying to
debate me about things that I can't even
create any understanding about we're
debating other than they want more
followers for me to jump in which is
amazing I appreciate it I'm humbled but
it's tough because I don't even know who
you are
[Music]
the Lions here bet you wish you stayed
at home
I am I
now I feel like I feel like when I see
you together and go into the black hole
where we going what are we doing guys
come on come on trout I don't do
logistics blog this has been
well-established
I don't do logistics babban that's on
you by the way Wendy rock and iris are
here they helped me with logistics I
feel like you just tagged along for the
ride what do you have to say for
yourself babban just add it to my list
yeah I don't do logistics I don't do
everything around here
I try to do everything it's not that I'm
fancy I just don't [ __ ] do logistics
I'm not gonna look at my [ __ ] number
I gave you the [ __ ] number
me you weren't doing [ __ ] trout and I
actually went to go get some business
you were just
you wouldn't bad when we're sitting and
like a nicely lit lobby just hanging out
you know okay I'm interested
[Music]
so I looked a little bit of this
business quite a bit obviously says
different you know dynamics thinking but
I mean [ __ ] you guys know this if you
guys if you guys care about the
five-year macro of the business which
you may or may not care about being a
human as an as an employee within the
organization but for legacy purposes and
like I'm sure you guys have pride and
are good human beings your company has
to do real [ __ ] in 2018 or ninth and 19
or it gets real vulnerable real fast you
guys have to at all costs
win on long-form video on Facebook it
can fundamentally change your brand
positioning you have to become religious
about understanding what that means with
or without us you have to it's the
underpriced attention that can give you
a chance to reframe your brand to three
to five different significance sets at
the lowest possible cost
in lieu of people wanting to go check
out fancy new places
you're not gonna renovate your entire
place you know what I mean you're not
going to deploy the capital so they're
gonna get real consideration just
because it's new you guys have you guys
have to disproportionally story too you
have to be a hundred fifty index not to
take a big punch in the mouth so you
better start fast
[Applause]
screams huh
what happened
am i losing a viewer am i losing a
viewer and your mom cuz you're not on as
much exactly right
mama Schroeder I promise you I will use
me and more content because I'll do
anything for ratings about it no joke
oh that let's go I want you to I want
Senate seal clip it they'll be in that
will be in it that little let's go I
literally want it at me
let's go clip to pop up randomly let's
go for like 11 straight vlogs in a row
where it makes no sense got it you'll
pass them on to the team good for you
well listen you've got you should go
tend to that I have to it really amazing
to incredible women that I work with one
from one for who both reached out to me
as a mentor of like you know should I go
do this should I go do that and you know
that when I emailed you the other day I
was and I was in the second of those two
meetings in two days and I said wait a
minute I got so I I remembered I kind of
recalled from our call so I'd like to
introduce you to them one his name it
was that now she's been a five years
amazing senior kind of like a real
player and the other one his name is oh
she's younger good okay well listen it's
a home run like these two women are
gonna be winners in life they'd be
blessed to spend an hour with you half
an hour with you so do you want me to do
that on email or text you're not gonna
be able to use a lot of that content
beat the [ __ ] out of it but I'm just
introducing people and it's gonna be
wins for them and I'm not looking for
anything in return karma points to the
[ __ ] max like sure in nineteen years
could one of them give me business sure
more likely and in sixteen years could
one of them take an hour meeting with
Misha because she wants to learn
something from them probably but more
importantly the [ __ ] world doesn't
lie you know there's a great thing in
basketball it says ball don't lie you
know one like there's a [ __ ] foul
and then the guy misses both free throws
and you're like ball don't lie Rasheed
Wallace used to always said I feel like
world don't lie you do the right thing
[ __ ] works out at the end I play under
the [ __ ] thesis of
don't line just took how long was that
I'm gonna actually give you example of
this gonna be a great clip how long was
that goddamn call that call was two
minutes in two minutes when the biggest
CEOs in in the world top one top 500
companies on introducing two young
talents to them it's just gonna be a win
I'm now out of the equation
two minutes doing good love for three
people two people meeting one person
separately who knows what happens but
world don't lie do the right thing
expect nothing in return and just in
nineteen years six years more months
from now I'm in some place where like oh
do I want to do that by the way let me
tell you why I want to do that you did
[ __ ] do the right thing everybody's
worried about themselves best way to
worry about yourselves is to do for
other people I know this is not
something like religious joint fine not
reading the Bible and knowing that stuff
I don't know but I promise you this it's
practical as [ __ ] world don't lie
Instagram Instagram Instagram Instagram
what up big up stall seventeen hundreds
of you crazy two thousand people like
four seconds Bitcoin you know bought my
Bitcoin in 2014
haven't have had played with it a little
bit think there's so many more experts
than me hence why I haven't talked about
it it's good to put this in the vlog
actually reason I haven't gotten veep on
cryptocurrency blockchain aetherium
Bitcoin litecoin is I don't feel like I
know as much as most people and I don't
like to talk about [ __ ] when I don't
know as much as other people
I think there's better sources I have
intuitions I'm marinating I'm back at
the lab aka my head right now trying to
get educated whether it's voice whether
it's cryptocurrency whether it's a
couple other things small business
marketing by the way there's a weird one
I'm gonna take late December early
January to walk the beach a little bit
and think and I'm gonna come out guns
and [ __ ] blaze and like I ever do
like I always do in January and I
promise you vlog
I promise you and three I'm live I will
bring straight buck and thunder and
pound it down your mouth for free and
when I get to it like if you go like
strain and write like kind of back on
the highway or if I kept going straight
right
yeah if we kept em straight you have to
take a right huh what's so funny oh good
job a man in my old stomping grounds 94
to 98 Gary very different character yeah
I know this air is super well this is
this is the yeah this is this is the
train station right
oh this exactly right uh-huh
god I haven't been here in a while boy
do I love math and do I hate the
Patriots what are interesting like I
really do weirdly enough people don't
know I love Boston really hate the New
England Patriots how'd you find they
sent me a postcard in the mail I filled
it out correct well it works that's
amazing actually the fact that I
literally picked my college in direct
mail the target must have been like
bottom 1% ranked in the class they
literally look like I feel like they
like we're like the segmentation was
like ridiculously punted school for the
last decade
[Music]
go
learned a lot right it's so crazy Nate I
told you so much right but what do you
really think like it is kind of weird
right like I like it it's super cool
it's super interesting hey everybody it
is your favorite time every vlog got a
quick transition every time the greatest
superhero ever has made his way to
Boston look at that shot huh let me see
this fun I feel like I'm now good at
this shots nice right like but how do
you zoom in oh my god I got it don't
touch it's nice Boston good job all
right here you go favorite superhero
ever
the by the way I can't wait you think
you think I sold a lot of sneakers Nate
you think there's a lot of case with
sold when the action figure comes out I
think the airport Gary action figure
Hasbro Mattel call me I think the I
think the action figure is real like I'm
telling you the comments are gonna roll
in right now like I think the action
figure it is your favorite time folks I
am headed to Sweden to greet a superhero
that you've ever seen
coming to be airport gallery
yeah I mean yeah that's such a good
question good job Pavan that's something
I don't see iris served Iraq asking a
little deeper explanation for the
origins of one of the great super heroes
of all time you know spider-man was bit
by a spider Superman I'm meant for that
I need to get cozy
you know the key airports for me is it's
like my home I get cozy
I get work done I get in that like kind
of like I get with I'm like one with the
airport and so I have to get real cozy
oh wait a minute Babbitt we have the
same we live the same like airport I
read all the time oh you mean your
Airport Tyler in real life at all time
base but I have to wear other clothes
because I do something for a living
exactly I gotta get I got to get one
with the airport so in this Skeeter I
get real cozy I feel real calm I can
just get my work done so heading to
Sweden looking forward to it
Stockholm stand up
[Music]
you
[Music]
you